There's a gap between theory and practice, and it's an annoying gap. Michael was learning how to box. His punches had some power. He was sparring in these little matches. He was feeling pretty tough. He was feeling really tough, actually. And then, one night, he's walking home on a deserted street and somebody picks a fight with him. Which in a way is exactly what he wanted. When you're learning to fight, you kind of dream that happening.
理论和实践之间存在差距，而且这种差距非常令人恼火。迈克尔当时正在学习拳击。他的出拳很有力。他在那些小比赛中进行实战练习。他觉得自己挺强悍的。事实上，他感觉非常强悍。然后，一天晚上，他走在一条荒凉的街道上回家，有人找他茬。这在某种程度上正是他想要的。当你学习打架时，你总是梦想着发生这种情况。
Because your moment will come. And I certainly thought that I was bad ass. And this guy wanted to mess with me. He was trying to mug me. He was trying to beat me up. I don't know what he was trying to do.
因为你的时刻会到来。我当然认为自己是个硬汉。这个家伙想找我麻烦。他想抢劫我。他想揍我。我不知道他到底想干什么。
And what he's saying to you?
他当时对你说了什么？
Oh, he's asking me if I have any money. He's mad at me because I'm not talking to him. He's asking me if I'm scared. And he kept grabbing me. And I was certainly getting kind of freaked out, because there wasn't anybody else around. And the street was really dark.
哦，他在问我有没有钱。他很生气，因为我不理他。他在问我是不是害怕。他不停地抓我。我确实开始有点吓坏了，因为周围没有其他人。而且街道非常黑。
Was he a big guy?
他是个大块头吗？
He was bigger than I was. And I turned around, and I really kind of intended to hit him. I wanted to hit him. But I just wasn't prepared. So I slapped him. And it wasn't one of those kind of "I challenge you to a duel" slaps. It was big. It was just a big, girly slap. He looked really surprised. His eyes were really wide open like he-- I don't think that either one of us could believe that I'd actually slapped him. And I slapped him again.
他比我壮。我转过身，真的打算打他。我想打他。但我没准备好。所以我扇了他一巴掌。那不是那种“我向你决斗”式的耳光。那是一记响亮的、十足的、女孩子气的耳光。他看起来非常惊讶。他的眼睛瞪得很大，好像——我觉得我们俩都无法相信我竟然扇了他一巴掌。我又扇了他一巴掌。
There was everything that his training to do in a real fight. And then there was what really happened. There was a gap between theory and practice.
他所有的训练在实战中都用上了。但现实中发生的却是另一回事。理论和实践之间存在着差距。
Heather was eight years old, on a school trip, on the bus, and she had to pee, badly. And the bus get stuck in traffic. Here's how she remembers it now that she's an adult. She says that her eight-year-old brain came up with a theory.
希瑟八岁时，在一次学校旅行的公交车上，她憋尿憋得厉害。公交车被堵在车流中。这就是她成年后对这件事的回忆。她说她八岁的大脑想出了一个理论。
I devised a plan because my little bladder was about to give out. And I decided that I was in the middle of the bus. I had a seat to myself. I thought I can pee really quietly, just kind of inch over my seat and go to the bathroom and no one will ever know.
我制定了一个计划，因为我的小膀胱快要撑不住了。我决定，因为我坐在公交车中间，周围是我自己的座位，我想我可以悄悄地撒尿，只要稍微挪到座位边上就行，没人会知道。
Inch over my seat, you mean like pee on the floor?
挪到座位边上，你的意思是尿在地板上？
Like pee on the floor. Like just kind of very quietly pee on the floor. No one will know.
就是尿在地板上。就像那样非常安静地尿在地板上。没人会知道。
That was the theory. You may be able to guess how this worked out in practice.
这就是那个理论。你大概能猜到这在实践中会是什么结果。
So I inched forward in my seat and I peed. So that's fine.
所以我挪到座位前面撒了尿。所以那挺好的。
Right.
对。
It's working. The kids, the obnoxious boys, they're yelling at each other. The girls are talking, gossiping, whatever. It's actually working. I even felt a little clever. But then the bus lurches forward. I hadn't realized that the pee wouldn't stay put. That when the bus lurched forward, the pee would roll backwards. And all of a sudden, in the back of the bus, I hear, "It's pee!" All hell breaks loose on the bus. Everybody started leaping around the bus, all known bus rules were off. You didn't have to sit still anymore. You didn't have to talk quietly to your neighbor. You could scream. You could leap over the seats. And the only kid that didn't move, was me, which I realize now is what incriminated me.
它奏效了。孩子们，那些讨厌的男孩们，在大声吵嚷。女孩们在聊天、嚼舌根，诸如此类。它实际上奏效了。我甚至觉得自己有点聪明。但随后公交车猛地向前一冲。我没意识到尿不会待在原地。当公交车向前猛冲时，尿会向后流。突然间，在公交车后部，我听到有人喊：“是尿！”公交车上一片混乱。每个人都开始在车厢里跳来跳去，所有已知的公交规则都不作数了。你不需要再安安静静地坐着了。你不需要再和邻座低声细语了。你可以尖叫。你可以跳过座位。而唯一没动的孩子就是我，我现在意识到这正是让我露馅的原因。
The whole thing pretty much cemented her position at the bottom of the social hierarchy in elementary school for a few years. Kids called her the Peeer, Peezilla. They'd leave yellow crayons for her, sitting on her desk.
这件事在接下来的几年里基本上巩固了她在小学社会等级最底层的地位。孩子们叫她“尿尿鬼”、“尿斯拉”。他们会在她的课桌上放黄色的蜡笔。
From the time that we're very young, so much of our life is just making a guess at how things are going to come out-- making a little theory, taking our shot, and then living with the reality of what we've done. It happens in our personal lives. It happens in every kind of group decision. Somebody has a theory about what it will accomplish to invade Iraq, or to cut taxes, or to make a movie starring Ben Affleck and JLo, together as hit men. And they got their theory, they take their shot, they wait for the results.
从我们很小的时候起，我们生活中的大部分内容就是在猜测事情会如何发展——制定一个小理论，尝试一下，然后接受我们所做之事的现实。这发生在我们的个人生活中。它发生在各种集体决策中。有人有一个关于入侵伊拉克、减税，或者拍一部由本·阿弗莱克和詹妮弗·洛佩兹联袂主演的杀手电影能带来什么成果的理论。他们有了他们的理论，他们尝试了，然后等待结果。
Today on our show, the annoying gap that results. The annoying gap between theory and practice. We have three case examples for you.
今天我们的节目主题就是由此产生的恼人差距。理论与实践之间的恼人差距。我们为您准备了三个案例。
Act One, Rock, Paper, Computer. Jack Hitt in that act explains the alarming difference between theory and practice when it comes to these new-fangled computerized voting machines. Act Two, Detroit Is in the House. An idealistic guy who's done lots of community work ends up representing for Detroit, in the state legislature, where he's witnessing the daily reality of democracy up close, for the first time. Act Three, Zero Divided by Zero Is Still Zero, What happens if you're poor and do everything right, all your budgeting, all your choices? Are you actually any better off?
第一幕，石头、剪子、电脑。杰克·希特在这一幕中解释了在这些新型电脑投票机方面，理论与实践之间令人担忧的差异。第二幕，底特律在行动。一个有着丰富社区工作经验的理想主义者最终在州议会代表底特律，在那里他第一次近距离目睹了民主的日常现实。第三幕，零除以零仍然是零。如果你贫穷并且把一切都做对了，所有的预算，所有的选择，会发生什么？你的境况真的会变好吗？
Stay with us.
请留下来。
Act One, Rock, Paper, Computer. Since the Florida chad nightmares back in 2000, a lot of communities around the country have been speeding up their purchase of new computerized touch-screen voting machines. These are designed to streamline the process of counting votes. They're designed to eliminate potential human error. That's the theory anyway. Jack Hitt explains how it works out in practice.
第一幕，石头、剪子、电脑。自2000年佛罗里达州的选票丑闻以来，全国各地的许多社区都在加速购买新型电脑触摸屏投票机。这些机器旨在简化计票过程。它们旨在消除潜在的人为错误。至少理论上是这样。杰克·希特解释了它在实践中是如何运作的。
With the bright clean world of touch-screen voting booths coming to so many precincts in America these days, I felt a little nostalgic walking into my local firehouse recently to vote for my mayor. It was to say the least, quaint. I brought along my two daughters. And our local alderwoman, Alfreda Edwards, was there to say good morning. Her regular opponent, Charlie Pillsbury, shook our hands too. The poll workers, about three or four of them, made a grand fuss signing me in. There were poll watchers there as well, the folks from the opposing parties, who ensure that the process moves along honestly. We all drank coffee and chatted about the raging issue in our neighborhood, the location of a new public school. Then a precinct captain pointed me to the booth. And I let my girls plink down the tiny levers. And after fighting about just who got to pull the big red handle, I won. We said goodbye to everybody and left.
随着触摸屏投票站这一明亮整洁的世界如今走进了美国的许多选区，我最近走进当地消防站为我的市长投票时感到了一丝怀旧。退一步说，这很古雅。我带上了我的两个女儿。我们当地的市议员阿尔弗雷达·爱德华兹在那里说早上好。她的常规对手查理·皮尔斯伯里也和我们握了手。民调工作人员，大约三四个，忙着为我登记，大惊小怪。那里也有民调观察员，即来自反对党的成员，他们确保投票过程诚实地进行。我们喝着咖啡，聊着我们社区最热门的话题，即新公立学校的选址。然后一名选区长官指引我走进投票间。我让我的女儿们按下那些微小的杠杆。在争论到底由谁来拉那个大红柄之后，我赢了。我们向每个人告别并离开了。
But this old world is soon to pass. Sure, there will still be poll workers. But the touch-screen voting booths will eliminate a lot of what those folks did. Instead of people running around with pieces of paper, computers will talk by modem and produce the vote totals.
但这个旧世界很快就要过去了。当然，仍然会有民调工作人员。但触摸屏投票站将淘汰掉那些人所做的大部分工作。不再需要人们带着纸张到处跑，电脑将通过调制解调器进行对话并产生投票总数。
It's madness. It's madness.
这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。
That's Jim March. He's a professional lobbyist by day in California. And he's been fretting a lot about the software running on these machines. Only three companies make them. And recently the biggest one of them, Diebold, accidentally left its supposedly secure voting software sitting on its web site, for anyone to download. And when people like Jim, who knows computers, looked at it, they were alarmed at how easy it would be to hack in and cause some real trouble.
那是吉姆·马奇。他白天是加州的一名专业游说者。他一直对运行在这些机器上的软件感到担忧。只有三家公司制造这些机器。最近其中最大的一家公司迪堡，意外地将其所谓的安全投票软件留在了他们的网站上，任何人都可以下载。当像吉姆这样懂电脑的人看到它时，他们对这种极其容易被黑客入侵并造成严重麻烦的可能性感到震惊。
Literally alter votes, alter passwords, alter every single aspect of the file without a password of your own required and without leaving an audit trail as to what you're doing.
实际上可以篡改选票、修改密码、更改文件的每一个方面，而无需你自己的密码，也不会留下你正在做什么的审计记录。
OK. Well, I have a computer in front of me. And I have the software, which I've downloaded from a public access site. So let's rig an election, Jim.
好吧。我面前有一台电脑。我下载了从公共访问网站上获取的软件。那么，让我们来操纵一次选举吧，吉姆。
Absolutely. Let's start by running--
绝对可以。让我们从运行开始——
Jim's in California. I'm in Connecticut on a friend's PC. The first thing Jim has me do is open Diebold's software called Global Election Management Systems or GEMS and go to where the password is stored. We peel the password off like a piece of scotch tape and replace it with our own.
吉姆在加州。我在康涅狄格州朋友的电脑上。吉姆让我做的第一件事是打开迪堡公司名为“全球选举管理系统”（GEMS）的软件，并转到存储密码的地方。我们像撕下一块透明胶带一样撕掉密码，并用我们自己的密码替换它。
OK. It asked me for a password.
好吧。它向我索要密码。
Yup. Under password, put in-- well, pick one.
没错。在密码栏下，输入——嗯，选一个吧。
Let's see. How about D-E-M-O-C-R-A-C-Y? OK.
让我看看。D-E-M-O-C-R-A-C-Y（民主）怎么样？好的。
OK. And hit OK.
好的。然后点击确定。
OK.
好的。
To demonstrate how this works, we don't hack into a real election. Instead, Jim gives me some old voter data that was part of the primary for the California governor's race in 2002. Essentially what I have in front of me is what a hacker would see if he got inside the system on voting day.
为了演示它是如何运作的，我们没有黑入真实的选举。相反，吉姆给了我一些旧的选民数据，那是2002年加州州长竞选初选的一部分。本质上，我面前的就是黑客在投票日进入系统后所看到的内容。
Now go to the Slow Primary 2002.
现在去“2002年慢速初选”文件夹。
Yeah.
好的。
Open it. And put in the same password that you put in for Jack, which is democracy.
打开它。输入你为杰克输入的同一个密码，就是“民主”。
Wow.
哇。
You're in.
你进去了。
And then we change vote totals, which was no more difficult than just typing in different numbers over the old ones. Of course, you might think the system would track such changes and they could be discovered. But then Jim shows me how to clean up my trail and make my escape. He takes me to the audit log, a spreadsheet detailing every change made to the database, every instance when someone has logged in with the date and time, down to the very second of each command. I can see all the history of what's happened here, including my own tampering, all the keystrokes I just made. Jim has me drag the mouse down the page and highlight most of this history.
然后我们更改投票总数，这并不比在旧数字上输入新数字更难。当然，你可能认为系统会跟踪这些更改，并且它们可能会被发现。但吉姆随后向我展示了如何清理我的足迹并掩盖行踪。他带我去了审计日志，这是一个详细记录了对数据库所做的每一个更改、每一个登录实例的电子表格，精确到每个命令的日期和时间，甚至精确到秒。我可以看到这里发生的所有历史记录，包括我自己的篡改行为，我刚才按下的每一个键。吉姆让我把鼠标拖过页面，高亮显示大部分历史记录。
All that's now black, correct?
所有这些现在都是黑色的，对吧？
Umm, yes.
嗯，是的。
Good. Hit the delete key.
很好。按下删除键。
Yeah. There it went. Wow.
是的。它消失了。哇。
Oh yeah. It's glorious. Do you understand? Even though you don't know what the proper password for the file is, you can restore it to its original condition and hide your traces.
哦，是的。太棒了。你明白了吗？即使你不知道文件的正确密码，你也可以将其恢复到原始状态并隐藏你的踪迹。
For months this software has been making the rounds on the internet, a kind of play toy for hackers. Especially since last July, when a Johns Hopkins University report on Diebold software scoffed that protections were, quote "far below the most minimal security standards." And went on to say that any insider, a poll worker, a Diebold software designer, or even, quote "a janitor" would be able to untraceably tamper with election results. In August, hackers started passing around a huge file, allegedly a collection of 13,000 pages of internal Diebold people emails written by its own employees that confirm just how easily penetrated the corporate software is.
几个月来，这个软件一直在互联网上流传，成为黑客的一种玩具。特别是在去年7月，当约翰·霍普金斯大学关于迪堡软件的报告嘲讽其保护措施时，称其“远低于最低安全标准”。报告接着说，任何内部人员，无论是民调工作人员、迪堡软件设计师，甚至“一名清洁工”，都能毫无痕迹地篡改选举结果。8月，黑客们开始传阅一个巨大的文件，据称是迪堡公司员工撰写的13,000页内部电子邮件的集合，证实了企业软件被渗透是多么容易。
From the beginning, Diebold has been trying to stop all this. First, they issued a point-by-point rebuttal to the Johns Hopkins report. And it said that the software being passed around the internet by people like Jim is not the version they currently use in their machines. Diebold hasn't talked directly to the press much about all this and didn't return my phone calls either. Most recently, Diebold started issuing cease and desist orders to all the internet users posting these files. They claimed to own the copyright on the 13,000 emails, while at the same time insisting that the documents may not be authentic.
从一开始，迪堡公司就试图阻止这一切。首先，他们对约翰·霍普金斯大学的报告发布了逐点反驳。它称，像吉姆这样的人在互联网上传阅的软件并非他们目前在机器中使用的版本。迪堡公司并没有就此事与媒体进行太多直接交流，也没有回复我的电话。最近，迪堡开始向所有发布这些文件的互联网用户发出勒令停止通知。他们声称拥有这13,000封电子邮件的版权，同时坚称这些文件可能不是真实的。
All of this got seriously complicated on Halloween when a second touch-screen voting company, Sequoia, had to admit that they too had left an unprotected copy of their voting software on the internet. I called one of the country's foremost specialists on just such catastrophes, Rebecca Mercuri, the president of Notable Software, a computer security firm, and now a research fellow at Harvard's Kennedy School of Government. I wanted to find out just how much danger we're in and if there's some way to stop people from hacking in and changing votes during a real election.
所有这一切在万圣节变得极其复杂，当时第二家触摸屏投票公司Sequoia不得不承认，他们也将未受保护的投票软件副本留在了互联网上。我打电话给全国此类灾难的顶尖专家之一，Notable Software（一家电脑安全公司）总裁、现任哈佛大学肯尼迪政府学院研究员丽贝卡·默丘里。我想弄清楚我们处于多大的危险之中，以及是否有什么方法可以阻止人们在真实选举中黑入并更改选票。
I don't know and quite frankly I don't care. That's not the issue.
我不知道，坦率地说，我也不在乎。那不是重点。
Not the issue? Hacking into voting software when step-by-step instructions to do what Jim showed me are posted on the internet?
不是重点？当吉姆展示的操作步骤说明都发布在互联网上时，黑入投票软件不是重点吗？
There's a lot of hullabaloo, but in my opinion that was not as big a deal as has been made out about it in the writings that I've seen. It's not.
有很多大惊小怪的事情，但在我看来，这并不像我在所看到的文章中被描述的那样重要。根本不是。
For Mercuri, the hacking angle is the least of it. The problem is far more fundamental. The problem is that current touch-screen technology, even when it works perfectly, can't do one of the most basic things the old analog machines did. It can't show you proof that your vote was counted accurately.
对默丘里来说，黑客攻击的角度只是最小的问题。问题远为根本。问题在于，目前的触摸屏技术，即使在完美运行时，也无法完成老式模拟机器所能完成的最基本的事情之一。它无法向你展示你的选票被准确计入的证据。
To understand why this would be difficult for a computer, you have to remember that voting machines must accomplish two slightly opposing things. First, they have to give people a way to vote without anyone finding out who they voted for. In other words, they have to provide total anonymity. But they also have to provide what is known in the voting machine business as auditability. That means if there were to be a recount, there's got to be some kind of paper trail to ensure the votes were counted correctly.
要理解为什么这对电脑来说很困难，你必须记住，投票机必须完成两件略有冲突的事情。首先，它们必须提供一种让人投票的方法，而不让任何人发现他们投给了谁。换句话说，它们必须提供完全的匿名性。但它们还必须提供投票机业务中所谓的“可审计性”。这意味着如果需要重新计票，必须有某种纸质记录来确保选票被正确计入。
Computers are not really very good at doing anonymous things that are also accurately audited. When we do an audit in the computer, we record every single action and transaction that goes along. If someone recorded down the voters in the sequence in which they went in, that would reveal how they voted. And that becomes a problem in creating the voting system.
电脑并不擅长做既匿名又准确审计的事情。当我们用电脑进行审计时，我们会记录随之而来的每一个操作和交易。如果有人按顺序记录下选民进入的顺序，那就会泄露他们是如何投票的。这成为创建投票系统的一个问题。
The old voting system solved this problem in a graceful, analog way. Punch card technology literally left an anonymous paper trail, the punch card ballots. But what about those lever machines? They're just giant clicking odometers. You can't recount those votes. Are they any different in that way from the computer technology?
旧的投票系统以一种优雅、模拟的方式解决了这个问题。打孔卡技术确实留下了匿名的纸质记录，即打孔卡选票。但那些杠杆式机器呢？它们只是巨大的咔哒作响的里程表。你无法重新计算那些选票。它们在这一点上与电脑技术有什么不同吗？
To put it simply, it's a vast world of difference. With the lever machine, you can open it up. And you can actually see the gears and levers and you can see that they're all connected together. And then you can test it out and make sure that it works properly. And you can see whether it's working properly. You can see it visually with your eyes. When we open up these electronic voting machines, even if they have all the buttons in the right place on the front, when you open them up inside, there's nothing to see.
简单地说，它们有着天壤之别。对于杠杆机，你可以打开它。你可以真正看到齿轮和杠杆，你可以看到它们是如何连接在一起的。然后你可以测试一下，确保它正常工作。你可以看到它是否工作正常。你可以亲眼看到它。当我们打开这些电子投票机时，即使它们前部的所有按钮都在正确的位置，当你打开内部时，什么也看不到。
Strangely, it was the low techness of the lever machine that made it safe. Poll workers understood how they worked. And one of the things the poll watchers, the two representatives from the different parties, typically did at the beginning of a voting day was look inside to see if there had been any tampering. And then easily test to see that a vote goes to the right candidate. Then they'd wind back the machine to zero, and the voting day would begin. Now they're not allowed to do this.
奇怪的是，正是杠杆机的低技术含量使其安全。民调工作人员了解它们的工作原理。而民调观察员——来自不同政党的两名代表——在投票日开始时通常做的其中一件事就是查看内部，看看是否有任何篡改。然后轻松测试以确保选票投向了正确的候选人。然后他们将机器回转到零，投票日就开始了。现在他们不被允许这样做。
They can't really check to see if the machines work because they no longer understand what the machines do. The computer companies do the checking for them, and provide them with a list of instructions explaining how to turn the machines on. The poll workers have no choice but to trust the company.
他们无法真正检查机器是否工作，因为他们不再了解机器的功能。电脑公司代替他们进行检查，并向他们提供了一份操作说明书，解释如何启动机器。民调工作人员别无选择，只能信任该公司。
The thing about these new machines is all it is, is a procedure. And all you can say is that you followed the procedure properly.
关于这些新机器的事情是，它仅仅是一个程序。你只能说你正确遵循了程序。
What you're saying is that we have the worst of both worlds. We have no paper and no way of looking at the system that's operating it.
你的意思是说，我们拥有了两种世界中最糟糕的情况。我们既没有纸张，也没有办法查看正在运行的系统。
Right. Exactly.
对。正是如此。
Somehow, it gets worse. Even if we wanted to train Republican and Democratic poll workers in basic software testing so they could do what they used to do, we're no longer allowed to.
不知何故，情况变得更糟了。即使我们想对共和党和民主党的民调工作人员进行基础软件测试培训，以便他们能做过去做的事情，我们也已不再被允许了。
The way these machines are installed, they're protected like Coca-Cola. It's a trade secret law, which says that no one's allowed to find out what's inside of them. And in fact if somebody reveals it, they'll be convicted of a felony because they're purchased under a secret agreement. It's purchased with a trade secret protection on it. They're tested in secret. And I know that all the election officials always say, well, it was tested and it was certified. Well, all that's a secret too. And so even if we want questions about how was it was tested, how it was certified, we can't find out.
这些机器的安装方式像可口可乐一样受到保护。这是一种商业秘密法，规定任何人都不允许查明其中的内容。事实上，如果有人泄露了它，他们将被判犯有重罪，因为它们是根据秘密协议购买的。它是在商业秘密保护下购买的。它们是在秘密中进行测试的。我知道所有选举官员总是说，好吧，它经过了测试和认证。好吧，所有这些也是秘密。所以即使我们想问它是如何测试的，它是如何认证的，我们也无法查明。
How did we manage to privatize the most public thing we do in this democracy?
我们是如何设法将这个民主制度中最公开的事情私有化的？
It's the United States. What do you expect? It's capitalism.
这是美国。你还能期待什么？这就是资本主义。
Let's review. Our new and improved voting system has no way to do a recount and no way to look at the machines to see if they're working properly. So is there a solution to our streamlined, digital, paperless vote?
让我们回顾一下。我们改进后的新投票系统无法进行重新计票，也无法查看机器以了解它们是否正常工作。那么，对于我们这种精简、数字、无纸化的投票，有什么解决方案吗？
Paper.
纸。
That's it. Once again?
就是这样。再来一次？
Paper.
纸。
For years, Rebecca Mercuri has been going around with her revolutionary new idea, a touch-screen that generates a piece of paper. The voter can look at it to confirm the vote was registered correctly before it drops into an old-fashioned ballot box. Then if there were a dispute, anything from a machine malfunction to a suspected hacker, we could gather up the paper and do a recount. But the industry says it can't be done.
多年来，丽贝卡·默丘里一直带着她革命性的新想法到处奔走：生成纸质记录的触摸屏。选民可以在选票掉入老式投票箱之前查看它，以确认选票登记正确。然后，如果发生纠纷，从机器故障到涉嫌黑客攻击，我们都可以收集纸张并进行重新计票。但业界表示这做不到。
One of the things that they say is that the paper ballots will jam in the printers. And I really like that excuse since one of the companies, Diebold, makes the vast majority or a huge number of the ATMs in this country. And, in fact, none of those seem to have any problems with paper jamming. The paper is just flopping out, quite fine. Also when we come to the lottery tickets, gee, we have no problems with this jamming, even on those super lotteries where you got $100 million at stake. There might be long lines at the lottery ticket machine. But we don't hear about, oh, the paper jammed and we were unable to get our lottery ticket. I don't know anybody who's ever said that.
他们说的其中一点是纸质选票会堵塞打印机。我真的很喜欢这个借口，因为其中一家公司迪堡制造了这个国家绝大多数或很大一部分ATM机。事实上，那些机器似乎都没有出现纸张堵塞的问题。纸张出来得很顺畅，非常好。此外，当我们谈到彩票时，天哪，我们在那上面没有遇到堵塞问题，即使是在那些赌注高达1亿美元的超级彩票上。彩票机前可能会排很长的队。但我们从没听说过，哦，纸张堵塞了，我们无法拿到彩票。我不认识任何说过这种话的人。
This idea that we need to computerize everything and get away from paper is in no other place in the whole industry other than with voting machines. And in the thing that should be most critical to our democracy.
这种我们需要将一切电脑化并摆脱纸张的想法，在除投票机之外的任何行业都不存在。而在应该对我们民主最关键的事情上却出现了。
Why would they not want to do that?
他们为什么不想这样做？
Well, here's my theory. They looked at what happened in Florida. They saw a lot of paper. They saw a lot of people getting into a lot of hot water because of the way the election was conducted. And the last thing that an election official wants to have is a whole bunch of TV cameras and yelling people camped out on their front steps saying, count the votes, don't count the votes. And what did you do with your election? And so, if you make it impossible to recount the votes, then you're not going to have that problem, are you?
好吧，这是我的理论。他们看了佛罗里达发生的事情。他们看到了大量的纸张。他们看到很多人因为选举的进行方式而陷入困境。选举官员最不想看到的就是一大堆电视摄像机和叫嚷的人群在他们的台阶上驻扎，说着，清点选票，不要清点选票。你对你的选举做了什么？所以，如果你让重新计票变得不可能，那么你就不会遇到那个问题了，不是吗？
Avoiding scandal has already led to some strange events, one of which Mercuri participated in. In 2002, she was asked to investigate a local election where everyone agreed that the numbers for one candidate were way off. It happened of course in Florida.
规避丑闻已经导致了一些奇怪的事情发生，默丘里就参与过其中一件。2002年，她被要求调查一场地方选举，当时每个人都同意其中一位候选人的票数严重不对劲。当然，这件事发生在佛罗里达。
This guy was a very popular former mayor who was just getting back into politics one last time. And really, everybody knew him. And even if I had any doubts before I started getting involved with this case, when you walked down the street. people would come up to this guy and come up and shake his hand.
这家伙是一位非常受欢迎的前市长，这是他最后一次重返政坛。而且实际上，每个人都认识他。即使我在参与此案之前有任何怀疑，当你走在街上时，人们会走过来，走到这家伙面前，跟他握手。
She didn't think it was vote tampering or hanging chads or anything. She just thought that maybe the machine was malfunctioning. All she wanted to do something that not so long ago was pretty commonplace.
她不认为这是篡改选票或悬挂选票或任何其他东西。她只是认为机器可能出现了故障。她只想做一件不久前还很普通的事情。
We just wanted to wind it back to where you could cast board votes and see if it was recording them all correctly. And they wouldn't let us do that.
我们只是想把它回转到可以进行投票的状态，看看它是否记录正确。他们不让我们那样做。
Why?
为什么？
Because it was proprietary.
因为它是专有的。
What was proprietary about just practicing the vote again?
再次练习投票有什么专有的？
They said we weren't allowed to do that. It was proprietary.
他们说我们不被允许那样做。它是专有的。
This is crazy.
这太疯狂了。
Tell me about it. It was proprietary.
可不是吗。它是专有的。
But you're not asking to look at the code. You're just asking to like--
但你不是要求查看代码。你只是要求像——
No, I wasn't asking to look at the code. I just wanted to do a simple test of the machine.
不，我不是要求查看代码。我只是想对机器做一个简单的测试。
Wow.
哇。
Would you accept a car if they told you that you could test drive it by only making right turns? I mean that's ridiculous. I don't think so.
如果他们告诉你只能通过右转来试驾，你会接受一辆车吗？我的意思是那太荒谬了。我不这么认为。
But one other thing further than that, even if it were possible to create the world's perfect voting machine that was a piece of equipment and it worked perfectly and it recorded every single vote and tabulated them correctly, every single time, I think that it is contrary to the spirit of democracy for us to trust that.
但除了这一点之外，即使可能制造出世界上完美的投票机，它是一台设备，运行完美，每一次都正确记录和计算每一张选票，我认为我们去信任它也是违背民主精神的。
Oh yes, the spirit of democracy, the ghost in the machine. In other words, all that busyness at the local firehouse, Alfreda and Charlie out on the sidewalk, the poll watchers inside with their chatter, trading gossip, the tallies carefully noted, or the box of paper ballots carried off under lock and key. Sure, all of that can be replaced by software modems. But it assumes that voting is really just another transaction, like buying a book off the internet, which is where we're headed.
哦，是的，民主精神，机器里的幽灵。换句话说，在当地消防站的所有忙碌，阿尔弗雷达和查理在人行道上，里面的民调观察员在聊天，交换八卦，仔细记录票数，或者在锁和钥匙下运走的纸质选票箱。当然，所有这些都可以被软件调制解调器所取代。但这假定投票真的只是另一项交易，就像从互联网上买书一样，而这正是我们要去的方向。
Nowadays, no one sells the old mechanical lever booths anymore, too low tech. And with the punch cards disgraced in Florida, more and more precincts are turning to touch-screen. In 2002, President Bush signed into law the Help America Vote Act, which includes $700 million to replace punch card and lever voting equipment. Most recently, the city of Boston and the entire state of Maryland have become Diebold's newest customers, buying into the dream of touch-screen efficiency. So clean, so uncluttered, and free of controversy.
如今，没有人再销售旧的机械杠杆投票间了，技术含量太低。随着佛罗里达州打孔卡的蒙羞，越来越多的选区转向了触摸屏。2002年，布什总统签署了《帮助美国投票法案》，其中包括7亿美元用于更换打孔卡和杠杆式投票设备。最近，波士顿市和马里兰州全境成为了迪堡公司最新的客户，购买了触摸屏效率的梦想。如此干净，如此简洁，且没有争议。
Back when America first opened for business, Europeans were stunned that any country would center its founding on a piece of paper, the Constitution. They thought we were crazy. We had no monarchy, no direct authority from God, no divine right of kings. We put our faith in a flimsy piece of paper, because after all the noise dies down, that's all a democracy really is.
当美国刚开始运作时，欧洲人震惊于一个国家竟然会将立国之本建立在一张纸——宪法上。他们以为我们疯了。我们没有君主，没有来自上帝的直接权威，没有君权神授。我们将信仰寄托在一张薄薄的纸上，因为在所有的喧嚣平息之后，民主真正也就是如此而已。
Jack Hitt in New Haven. In elections this past week, there were new controversies for Diebold. Officials in California are saying that thousands of people may have cast their votes on software that hadn't been certified by the state, as required by California law. And some touch-screens failed in Maryland, prompting a lawsuit by Republicans.
杰克·希特在纽黑文。在上周的选举中，迪堡公司出现了新的争议。加州的官员们表示，数千人可能在未经州政府认证的软件上投了票，而这是加州法律所要求的。一些触摸屏在马里兰州也出现了故障，引发了共和党人的诉讼。
Coming up, more theory and practice. For instance, in theory you want to give $200 million to public radio so you donate to a very fine company, very fine news organization called National Public Radio in Washington, DC, without ever realizing that there is an equally worthy outfit called Public Radio International that also puts out some very fine programs, could use a little cash. But that was your theory. In practice, we actually won't hear about this at all in the second half of the show, which you'll hear in one minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, remember the name, when our program continues.
接下来，更多的理论与实践。例如，理论上你想向公共广播捐赠2亿美元，所以你捐给了一家非常好的公司，一家名为华盛顿特区国家公共广播电台的优秀新闻机构，却从未意识到还有一家同样值得尊重的名为公共广播国际的机构，它也制作一些非常好的节目，可以筹集一点资金。但那是你的理论。在实践中，我们在节目的后半部分其实根本不会听到这个，您将在从芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际（记住这个名字）节目继续后的第一分钟听到。
This is American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose some theme. And bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, the annoying gap between theory and practice. We have stories of people coming face to face with that gap. And we are at act two of our program. Act Two, Detroit in the House.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题。为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是理论与实践之间的恼人差距。我们有人们与这种差距面对面的故事。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，底特律在行动。
Ten months ago, a political newcomer was elected to the Michigan House of Representatives, not because he had any childhood dreams of being a politician or because he really loved the spotlight or because he wanted power of any sort actually. He just had some ideas about how to make things better in his community, from experience working in the community, plus a masters's degree in public policy, and a law degree. The voters agreed that his ideas were the best. They sent him off to the government to make those ideas happen. And that pretty much was when theory and practice started to diverge. Alex Blumberg spent three days with freshman state representative, Steve Tobocman.
十个月前，一位政坛新人当选为密歇根州众议院议员，不是因为他从小就梦想成为政治家，也不是因为他真的很喜欢聚光灯，或者实际上是因为他想要任何形式的权力。他只是对如何改善社区有一些想法，基于在社区工作的经验，加上公共政策硕士学位和法律学位。选民们一致认为他的想法是最好的。他们把他送进政府去实现这些想法。这基本上就是理论与实践开始分歧的时候。亚历克斯·布隆伯格与新任州议员史蒂夫·托博克曼一起度过了三天。
Here are other reasons Steve Tobocman shouldn't be in office. His district is 80% minority, but he's white. At the time of his campaign, he didn't have any actual experience in politics and he was up against a two-term incumbent. And he ran in the most old fashioned way possible, no radio or TV ads, no special interest money. He went out and knocked on doors, every single day for four months.
这是史蒂夫·托博克曼不应该担任公职的其他原因。他的选区80%是少数族裔，但他是个白人。在他竞选时，他没有任何实际的政治经验，而且他面对的是一位连任两届的现任议员。他以最老派的方式进行竞选，没有电台或电视广告，没有特殊利益集团的钱。他每天走出去敲门，连续四个月，每一天。
And you'd spend so many hours knocking. I mean your knuckles would be raw. You knees would hurt. Your hands would hurt. It's a tremendous weight loss program. I actually to maximize, and this is a little embarassing, but to maximize the number of doors I could knock on, I would run, I would literally sprint between the houses to save time. I literally would sprint between houses. So one day I was sprinting down the street and I kind of jogged into this guy's backyard. And he's like, "Are you OK. Are you OK?" And I said, "What do you mean?" And he said, "Well, I see a white guy running in this neighborhood. I figured he was under attack or something like that."
你会花那么多时间敲门。我的意思是你的指关节会磨破。你的膝盖会疼。你的手会疼。这是一种极好的减肥计划。实际上为了最大化——这有点令人尴尬，但为了最大化我能敲门的数量，我会跑，我真的会在房子之间冲刺以节省时间。我真的会在房子之间冲刺。有一天我冲下街道，我有点慢跑进了这个家伙的后院。他问，“你还好吗？你还好吗？”我说，“你是什么意思？”他说，“嗯，我看到一个白人在这个社区跑。我以为他被袭击了或者类似的事情。”
Steve's district is a poor inner city section of Detroit. A city's whose problems are legendary, of course. It has the nation's highest infant mortality rate, lost half its population since 1950. And to give you an idea of the size of its middle class, the total number of Starbucks in this the 10th largest city in the country, three. 13 fewer than at O'Hare Airport.
史蒂夫的选区是底特律贫穷的内城部分。底特律的问题当然是传奇性的。它的婴儿死亡率全国最高，自1950年以来失去了一半的人口。为了让你了解其中产阶级的规模，在这个国家第十大城市里，星巴克的总数只有三家。比奥黑尔机场少了13家。
Steve had been trying to fix Detroit's problems for years in various jobs with various neighborhood economic development groups. Mostly he fought slow, bureaucratic battles to get abandoned buildings either torn down or fixed up. He can tell you all sorts of modest specific ways that government could help improve things by streamlining the way federal block grants are distributed for example or selling condemned properties to community and church groups for a dollar or to groups to rehab and sell at a discount to low income families. But these ideas usually went nowhere.
史蒂夫多年来一直试图通过在各种邻里经济发展组织的各种工作来解决底特律的问题。大部分时间里，他进行缓慢、官僚的斗争，以求拆除或修缮废弃建筑。他可以告诉你政府可以通过流线型分配联邦整笔拨款的方式，或者以一美元的价格将查封的房产出售给社区和教会团体，或者出售给社区团体进行改造并以折扣价出售给低收入家庭，来以各种适度而具体的方式帮助改善情况。但这些想法通常毫无进展。
I mean Steve would come home for years and be frustrated, like you're working, you're working, you're working, and it seems like a good idea. And you can't get anything done about it.
我是说史蒂夫多年来回家时会感到沮丧，就像你正在工作，工作，工作，这看起来是个好主意。而你却无法完成任何事情。
This is Steve's wife, Sharon. She says that all this changed during a dinner Steve had with a mentor of his from grad school.
这是史蒂夫的妻子莎伦。她说这一切在史蒂夫与他研究生院的一位导师共进晚餐时改变了。
Basically he said, stop complaining and do more. Like if what's making it hard are a level of politicians or a level of bureaucracy, then get inside that bureaucracy and change that bureaucracy. And he came home and said, "I think I need to run for office. What do you think about that?" And I was like, oh [BLEEP].
基本上他说，别抱怨了，多做点事。如果让事情变得困难的是政客层面或官僚层面，那就进入官僚机构内部并改变官僚机构。他回家说，“我觉得我需要竞选公职。你觉得怎么样？”我说，哦，该死。
I always thought, well you run for office and that's really about ego and it's very self-serving. And somehow that conversation was different because this was a view that spoke to me in terms of making a difference.
我一直认为，嗯，竞选公职那是关于自我，非常自私自利。而那次谈话不知何故不同，因为这是一种与我产生共鸣的观点，即在做出改变方面。
So in other words, it made you think by becoming a politician you could actually do some good.
所以换句话说，这让你认为通过成为一名政治家，你实际上可以做点好事。
That was the thought. And every day you try and see if that's indeed the case.
那是当时的念头。每天你都要努力看看是否确实如此。
If you've ever wondered what the hell politicians do all day, I can say that if Steve Tobocman's any indication, a lot more than you do, pal. His workday begins at 7:00 or 8:00 AM. And this one includes among other things, a very dull hour plus tour of a social service facility, a 15-minute phone call with an Arab American constituent who believes her teenage son is being discriminated against in school, at the end of which Steve promises to call the principal.
如果你曾经想过政治家整天到底在做什么，我可以说明如果史蒂夫·托博克曼有任何迹象的话，他们做得比你多得多，伙计。他的工作日从早上7点或8点开始。这包括除此之外，一次非常沉闷的社会服务设施参观，与一名认为其十几岁的儿子在学校受到歧视的阿拉伯裔选民进行15分钟的电话交谈，在交谈结束时，史蒂夫承诺会给校长打电话。
And what would be a solution in your mind to the problem?
在你的心目中，解决问题的方案会是什么？
There's a lunch meeting with a business constituent who wants a favor, a staff meeting, some fund raising calls, and then in the evening, a two-hour town meeting in a high school gymnasium on the subject of insurance redlining.
有一个与想要获得好处的商业选民共进午餐的会议，一个员工会议，一些筹款电话，然后在晚上，在一个高中体育馆举行关于保险红线的两小时市民会议。
I just tried to buy a brand new car.
我刚才试着买一辆全新的车。
An angry crowd of 20 to 30 Detroit home and car owners complains about insurance rates that are almost 50% higher than rates right across the border in the suburbs.
一群愤怒的20到30名底特律房主和车主抱怨保险费率比郊区几乎高出50%。
The lowest I could get per month for insurance was $365 a month. The insurance would have been more than my car loan.
我能得到的最低月保费是每月365美元。保险费会比我的车贷还高。
Steve offers some suggestions. And one middle-aged Hispanic man, in a black satin varsity jacket and a baseball hat, grabs Steve by the arm and says, "We've never heard anyone talk so clearly about this before. You are the one who can help us. You are the light and we will follow you."
史蒂夫提出了一些建议。一名穿着黑色缎面大学外套、戴着棒球帽的中年西班牙裔男子抓住史蒂夫的胳膊说，“我们从未听过有人对此说得这么清楚。你是能帮助我们的人。你是光，我们会跟随你。”
You are the light. And we follow you.
你是光。我们跟随你。
Steve gets home at about 10:00 PM.
史蒂夫大约在晚上10点回家。
You are the light to me because I think there's treasure in every single time--
你是我的光，因为我认为每一次都有珍宝——
And now it's 7:00 AM the next morning. And though it's still dark outside, the light is up and driving to Lansing, the state capitol, in his blue Saturn station wagon, where at least in theory he'll be helping the people he met last night. The problem of course is that Steve works with 110 other Representatives and they're all driving up from their own town meetings, where their own constituents have been demanding action on their own quite different grievances.
现在是第二天早上7点。尽管外面仍然很黑，但光已经亮了，他开着蓝色的土星旅行车前往州首府兰辛，至少在理论上他将帮助他昨晚见到的那些人。当然，问题在于史蒂夫与另外110名代表一起工作，他们都从自己的市民会议上开车赶来，在那里他们自己的选民一直在要求对他们自己截然不同的怨愤采取行动。
Getting elected may give you a slightly louder voice, but it also sticks you into a much noisier crowd, the majority of whom couldn't care less about redlining or community development or frankly, the entire city of Detroit. And you don't care about their issues either. In fact, being a legislator involves spending a lot of time dealing with issues you have absolutely no interest in. Sometimes though, the issues you care least about can end up altering the course of your political career, issues with names like the Michigan Controlled Shareowner statute. In the car on the way to Lansing, Steve tells me the story.
当选可能会让你稍微响亮一点的声音，但也把你塞进了更嘈杂的人群，其中大多数人一点也不关心红线或社区发展，坦率地说，也不关心整个底特律市。你也不关心他们的问题。事实上，作为一名立法者涉及花费大量时间处理你完全不感兴趣的问题。虽然有时，你最不关心的议题最终可能会改变你的政治生涯，议题的名字如《密歇根受控股东法》。在去兰辛的车上，史蒂夫告诉了我这个故事。
I didn't know about it. And most people didn't know about it. Basically it was adopted in the mid-'80s to prevent hostile takeovers of Michigan companies, companies based in Michigan. And--
我不知道它。大多数人也不知道。基本上它是在80年代中期通过的，旨在防止对密歇根公司、总部设在密歇根的公司进行敌意收购。而且——
Now as a legislator facing a bill you don't care that much about, you have two choices. You can A, assume someone in your party has looked at the issue thoroughly and vote how that person tells you to. Or B, you can do all the research yourself and come to an independent position based entirely on your own principles and convictions. No one does B. Well, except for freshman legislators.
现在作为一名立法者，面对一个你不太关心的法案，你有两个选择。你可以A，假设你方阵营中有人已经彻底研究过这个问题，并按照那个人告诉你的方式投票。或者B，你可以自己完成所有的研究，并完全基于你自己的原则和信念形成一个独立的立场。没有人做B。好吧，除了新任立法者。
When I first got to the legislature, I think every vote, I used to sit at my desk on the floor and as every issue came up, I would study it and get as much information as possible before casting my vote.
当我刚到立法机构时，我想我每一次投票，我过去常坐在地板上的办公桌旁，当每个议题出现时，我会在投票前研究它并获得尽可能多的信息。
Do you think that like of the bills that the sort of people vote on, do you think that most of the people who are voting for the bill actually understand how it will impact once it's implemented?
你认为像那种投票议题，你认为大多数投票支持法案的人真的了解它在实施后会产生什么影响吗？
I think that you have a general gist of what the bill is trying to do. But in terms of understanding the specifics and that kind of thing and being able to articulate a detailed analysis, I think that it's virtually impossible.
我想你对法案试图做的事情有一个大概的了解。但在了解具体细节以及诸如此类的事情并能够阐述详细分析方面，我认为这几乎是不可能的。
So just a month or two into his new job, Steve found himself reading up on the Michigan Controlled Shareowner statute. which had come before the legislature at the urging of the Todman Group, a private mall development company based in Michigan and owned by the Todman family. They were trying to fight off a takeover by an even bigger mall development company called the Simon Group and they needed a loophole closed in the law to do that. After a couple late nights of research, Steve decided the Todmans were right. And he agreed to co-sponsor a bill fixing the loophole. And that's when all hell broke loose.
所以在他新工作才一两个月后，史蒂夫发现自己在阅读《密歇根受控股东法》，该法是在总部设在密歇根州、由托德曼家族拥有的私人购物中心开发公司托德曼集团的敦促下提交给立法机构的。他们试图抵御一家名为西蒙集团的更大的购物中心开发公司的收购，为了做到这一点，他们需要在法律中关闭一个漏洞。在进行了几个深夜的研究后，史蒂夫认为托德曼家族是对的。他同意共同发起一项修复漏洞的法案。这就是所有混乱开始的时候。
There were probably $2 billion at stake. The Todmans and the Simon Group had each hired their own army of lobbyists. All of a sudden there were a 100 or 200 people at committee meetings where usually they're only 20 or 30. Everyone took sides, business groups, unions, and of course, Steve's own party. The Democratic leadership approached him one day and told him to his horror that he was the only Democrat who had agreed to support the bill. Not only that, the Democrats were planning to run TV ads attacking the Todman supporters as tools of big business. And then came a pivotal caucus meeting, a closed door strategy session where the whole party discusses upcoming policies and positions.
可能涉及20亿美元。托德曼家族和西蒙集团各自雇佣了自己的游说团体大军。突然间，委员会会议上有100或200人，而通常只有20或30人。每个人都站队，商业团体、工会，当然还有史蒂夫自己的政党。民主党领导层有一天接近他，令他惊恐的是，他是唯一一个同意支持该法案的民主党人。不仅如此，民主党人还计划通过电视广告攻击托德曼的支持者是大商业的工具。然后是关键的党团会议，这是一个讨论即将到来的政策和立场的闭门战略会议。
There's one point in caucus where about five or six people have just blasted this bill. And used all of the sort of hyperbolic arguments that everybody had used against this bill, that the Todman family had given hundreds of thousands of dollars to Republicans and why should we be doing their business in the legislature? And this was based solely on campaign contributions. And I'm sitting there as a freshman thinking, man, do I look bad right now. And I'm going to look even worse when there's one Democratic vote on the floor. I mean boy, this is going to be embarrassing.
在党团会议中有个节点，大约五六个人刚刚抨击了这个法案。并使用了每个人反对该法案的所有夸张论点，即托德曼家族已经给了共和党人数十万美元，为什么我们应该在立法机构里处理他们的业务？这完全是基于竞选捐款。我作为一个新人坐在那里想，伙计，我现在看起来很糟糕。当楼层只有一票民主党赞成票时，我会看起来更糟。我的意思是天哪，这会很尴尬。
So basically, finally I'm about the seventh speaker. And at that point probably more out of fear than anything else, I get up and begin to talk about the bill.
所以基本上，最后我是第七个发言人。在那一点上，可能更多是出于恐惧而不是其他任何原因，我站起来开始谈论该法案。
Steve's colleagues still mention that speech to him. It was the speech of his young political career. He talked about what the bill would do to protect Michigan businesses and workers. He talked about jobs. He talked about Compuware, the big company owned by Peter Karmanos, that had just built a huge high rise in downtown Detroit.
史蒂夫的同事们仍然向他提起那次演讲。那是他年轻政治生涯的演讲。他谈到了该法案将如何保护密歇根的企业和工人。他谈到了就业。他谈到了由彼得·卡马诺斯拥有的、刚刚在底特律市中心建造了一座巨大高楼的大公司Compuware。
I got very passionate. And I started talking about Mr. Karmanos's investment in Compuware revitalizing the city of Detroit. And should Microsoft come and take over Compuware that we knew those jobs were going to leave. And downtown Detroit would be vacant. And all these horrible things would happen. And the tone of my voice rose. The passion in my voice rose. And we went out onto the floor and had the vote. And 22 of my 47 colleagues ended up voting with me. And as a result, it overwhelmingly passed the House. And then because of that kind of support, it passed through on the Senate. And last week, the governor signed the bill into law.
我变得非常有激情。我开始谈论卡马诺斯先生对Compuware的投资振兴了底特律市。如果微软来收购Compuware，我们知道那些工作将会流失。市中心底特律将会空置。所有这些可怕的事情都会发生。我的声音的音调升高了。我声音中的激情升高了。我们走到楼层并进行了投票。我的47名同事中有22人最终与我投票。结果，它以压倒性多数通过了众议院。然后因为那种支持，它在参议院通过了。上周，州长签署该法案成为法律。
And that when I think about what caused that much emotion, I certainly don't think it was the Michigan Controlled Shares statute. I think it was more the fear of being the lone vote for the horrible Todman bill.
而当我想想是什么导致了那么多的情绪时，我当然不认为它是《密歇根受控股东法》。我想它更多是害怕成为那份可怕的托德曼法案的唯一一张赞成票。
The Todman bill earned Steve a reputation as something of a rainmaker on the other side of the aisle. And the Republicans who were in charge of getting the bill signed into law were so grateful, they've actually helped Steve move some of his own legislation. But what's funny is that this vote, a vote that enhanced his political standing in his own party, gained him valuable allies on the other side of the aisle, not to mention brought about a positive change in the law, is a vote that he wouldn't have cast today. Steve no longer studies every bill that crosses his desk. He uses his time talking to colleagues, enlisting support for his own issues. If the Todman bill came before him today, he would have listened to his party, not learned anything about it, and voted against it.
托德曼法案为史蒂夫赢得了在另一侧阵营中作为“造雨者”的声誉。那些负责确保法案签署成为法律的共和党人非常感激，他们实际上帮助史蒂夫推动了他自己的一些立法。但有趣的是，这次投票，一次提高了他在自己党内政治地位的投票，在另一侧阵营为他赢得了宝贵的盟友，更不用说带来了法律上的积极变化，是他今天不会投出的投票。史蒂夫不再研究经过他桌面的每一项法案。他把时间花在与同事交谈，为他自己的议题争取支持上。如果托德曼法案今天出现在他面前，他会听从他政党的意见，什么都不了解，并投出反对票。
The House will come to order. I'd ask all members to take their seats.
众议院请肃静。请所有议员就座。
On the huge floor of the Michigan House of Representatives, nobody is coming to order. The 110 lawmakers, 63 Republicans and 47 Democrats, continue to mill around and cluster in small groups. There's a big fight brewing today over two bills, Senate Bill 252 and Senate Bill 560, both of which do essentially the same thing, which is impose fees on anyone who discharges pollution into the water. One of the bills deals with groundwater, the other rivers and lakes. In any event, in both of them, the more pollution you discharge, the higher your fee. For small organizations like a day camp with a septic system or a small veterinary office, the fees are in the hundreds of dollars. For large entities like the Ford Motor Company or the City of Grand Rapids, they can climb into the tens of thousands of dollars. The idea is that the bills will encourage everyone to pollute less because that will lower your fees and thus lead to clean drinking water for everyone.
在密歇根州众议院巨大的楼层上，没有人在肃静。110名立法者，63名共和党人和47名民主党人，继续在走动并在小团体中聚集。今天有两项法案正在酝酿一场大战，参议院法案252号和参议院法案560号，两者本质上做同样的事情，即对任何将污染排放到水中排放的人征收费用。其中一项法案处理地下水，另一项处理河流和湖泊。无论如何，在这两项法案中，你排放的污染物越多，你的费用就越高。对于像带有化粪系统的日营地或小型兽医诊所这样的小型组织，费用在数百美元。对于像福特汽车公司或大急流城市这样的大型实体，费用可能攀升到数万美元。其想法是，这些法案将鼓励每个人少污染，因为这会降低你的费用，从而引导每个人都有清洁的饮用水。
Nearly every state has fees like these. Michigan is one of just eight states that don't. OK. One other thing you should know, today's fee bills were the idea of Michigan's Democratic governor. And earlier in the year, she'd worked out a deal with the Republicans, who control both the House and the Senate in Michigan by fairly large majorities. Each party had agreed to put up a certain number of votes to pass the bill. And as of last week, the bills come out of committee and everything seemed to be going smoothly. Today though, it seems that the deal might have fallen apart and that Senate Bill 252 and Senate Bill 560 are in trouble. Steve points to the computer terminal at his desk.
几乎每个州都有这样的费用。密歇根是仅有的八个没有费用的州之一。好吧。你应该知道的另一件事是，今天的费用法案是密歇根州民主党州长的想法。今年早些时候，她与共和党人达成了一项协议，共和党人在密歇根州的众议院和参议院都以相当大的多数控制权。每个政党都同意拿出一定数量的选票来通过法案。截至上周，法案已从委员会中出来，一切似乎进展顺利。今天，协议似乎破裂了，参议院法案252和参议院法案560遇到了麻烦。史蒂夫指向他桌上的电脑终端。
As you can see from the legislative schedule, there are 10 amendments right now in the docket for 252, 13 amendments for Senate Bill 560 that are being planned. And probably an equal number from each party.
正如你从立法时间表所看到的那样，目前252号法案的案卷中有10项修正案，参议院法案560号有13项修正案正在计划中。而且可能每个政党有相同数量。
And that's a lot?
那很多吗？
That's a lot.
那很多。
Generally speaking, all the Republican amendments do the same basic thing. They exempt certain groups from having to pay the pollution discharge fees.
一般而言，所有的共和党修正案做同样基本的事情。它们豁免某些群体无需支付污染排放费。
The Chair recognizes Representative Drolet.
主席认可德罗莱特议员。
Thank you, Mr. Speaker.
谢谢，主席先生。
Representative Leon Drolet, a Republican from the Detroit suburbs, gets up and makes the case. He says the pollution discharge fees are excessive and they've been foisted on his constituents by the Democratic governor.
代表底特律郊区的共和党人莱昂·德罗莱特议员站起来陈述了理由。他说，污染排放费是过分的，而且是民主党州长强加给他的选民的。
And I'd like to review some of who these polluters are that we're making pay and what the governor is proposing in her executive fees. For one of the polluters, the Sable Valley Nursing Home, the government proposes a $6,000 fee on them. Big polluters, like the KPEC Fellowship Christian Church, will have to pay $4,000 additionally under this proposal. The Boy Scouts of America would have to pay $2,500 in new fees and redo their--
我想回顾一下这些我们让他们支付的污染者是谁，以及州长在她的行政费用中提议了什么。对于其中一个污染者，萨布尔谷疗养院，政府建议对他们征收6,000美元的费用。像KPEC团契基督教会这样的大污染者，根据这项提议将不得不额外支付4,000美元。美国童子军将不得不支付2,500美元的新费用并重新做他们的——
The line between political pandering and political belief is a hazy one. As I watch Representative Drolet, it seems his opposition is sincere. People tell me he's a principled and committed libertarian. If Steve sees himself as fighting on behalf of people who just want clean drinking water, Representative Drolet sees himself as fighting on behalf of people just trying to make an honest buck, without interference from the state. Both men think that if things ran their way, the world would be a lot better. And both men think that if things run the other guy's way, the world would go to hell in a hand basket.
政治讨好与政治信仰之间的界限是模糊的。当我看着德罗莱特议员时，似乎他的反对是真诚的。人们告诉我他是一位有原则且坚定的自由意志主义者。如果史蒂夫认为自己在为那些只想有清洁饮用水的人争取利益，那么德罗莱特议员认为自己在为那些只想赚点辛苦钱而不受国家干涉的人争取利益。这两个人都认为如果事情按照他们的方式运作，世界会好得多。这两个人都认为如果事情按照对方的方式运作，世界会陷入地狱。
Watching Representative Drolet, I realize sometimes democracy is not about getting your way.
看着德罗莱特议员，我意识到有时民主不是关于按照你的方式进行。
I don't support this amendment because--
我不支持这个修正案是因为——
It's making sure the other guy doesn't get his.
这确保对方无法达到他的目标。
It's the governor who's proposed these fees. It's the governor that made a deal to put them through the legislature. It's the governor that wants to charge Gene Ringley of Kleen Gene's Laundromat $2,000 additional a year. So let's let Gene Ringley, Jr. of Rosscommon, Michigan know who wants him to cough up the $2,000.
是州长提议了这些费用。是州长达成了将它们通过立法机构的协议。是州长想要向罗斯康蒙密歇根州Kleen Gene洗衣店的吉恩·林格利额外征收2,000美元一年。所以让我们让罗斯康蒙密歇根州的吉恩·林格利二世知道是谁想让他掏出那2,000美元。
Speeches like Drulet's make the Democrats on the other side of the aisle nervous, especially ones like Representative Jennifer Elkins, whose district is heavily Republican. She doesn't want Gene Ringley of Kleen Gene's Laundromat to think that she's taking $2,000 of his hard-earned money. And she sees that the Republicans are setting a political trap for her. Each of their amendments exempts some group of Michigan voters from this new government fee. If the Democrats oppose the amendments, the Republicans will use that against them at reelection time. She pulls Steve aside.
像德罗莱特那样的演讲让议会另一侧的民主党人感到紧张，特别是像詹妮弗·埃尔金斯议员那样的人，她的选区主要是共和党。她不希望Kleen Gene洗衣店的吉恩·林格利认为她正在拿走他2,000美元的血汗钱。她看到共和党人正在为她设置一个政治陷阱。他们的每个修正案都豁免了密歇根选民中的某些群体支付这种新的政府费用。如果民主党人反对修正案，共和党人将在连任时利用这一点来对付他们。她把史蒂夫拉到一边。
We're going to get hung on this [BLEEP]. When the Republicans were meeting, our names were brought up--
我们会被这件事吊死。当共和党人开会时，我们的名字被提到了——
She tells Steve she overheard the Republicans mentioning her name specifically as someone's target. But Steve tells her not to worry. The Democrats met earlier and agree there's no point falling into this trap the Republicans are setting. They won't challenge the Republicans on any of this. In other words, they're voting for all the exemptions.
她告诉史蒂夫，她无意中听到共和党人明确提到她的名字作为某人的目标。但史蒂夫告诉她不要担心。民主党人之前会面并同意陷入共和党人设置的这个陷阱是没有意义的。他们不会挑战共和党人。换句话说，他们正在投票赞成所有的豁免。
For the exemptions, we're all voting for the exemptions. They don't understand that's what we're doing.
对于豁免，我们都在投票赞成豁免。他们不明白这就是我们在做的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
They think we're going to fight among them on these little nonprofits and churches. And that's [BLEEP]. We're not going to take that heat. You should vote for every exemption.
他们认为我们会为了这些小非营利组织和教会而与他们争斗。那太扯了。我们不会承受那种压力。你应该为每一项豁免投票。
All in favor of the amendment will vote aye. All those opposed, nay. The Clerk will open the board.
所有赞成修正案的人将投票投赞成票。所有反对的人，投反对票。书记官将打开板面。
On a big light display board at the front of the chamber, member names light up as they press their vote buttons. Red means no. Green means yes. Steve is the floor manager for the Democrats today, meaning it's his job to make sure everyone else knows how to vote.
在议会前部的大型灯光显示板上，议员的名字在他们按下投票按钮时亮起。红色意味着不。绿色意味着是。史蒂夫今天是民主党人的楼层经理，这意味着他的工作是确保其他人知道如何投票。
Recommending green.
推荐绿色。
What do you mean?
你的意思是什么？
Why should we let them say oh, we protected you, and we didn't? That's [BLEEP]. They're all going to pass. You might as well be on there. Why should we let them vote for this and we have to take the heat on this?
我们为什么要让他们说，哦，我们保护了你，而我们没有？那太扯了。它们都会通过。你不妨也在那里。我们为什么要让他们为这个投票，而我们必须为此承担压力？
Green.
绿色。
All members voted? The Clerk will close the board. Tally, display, announce the vote.
所有议员投票了吗？书记官将关闭板面。计数，显示，宣布投票结果。
Mr. Speaker, on the question of adoption of the Bradstreet Amendment 2D, there are 102 aye votes and 3 nay votes.
主席先生，关于通过布拉德斯特里特修正案2D的问题，有102张赞成票和3张反对票。
The majority of the members electing and serving having voted in support of the Bradstreet Amendment 2D, it is adopted. If there are further amendments, the Clerk will read them.
大多数选举和任职的成员已投票支持布拉德斯特里特修正案2D，它已通过。如果有进一步的修正案，书记官将宣读它们。
The debate about the fee bills drags on long after this, for four hours until 6:00 PM, well past the time session usually ends. And one of the bills ends up passing. But the other one keeps getting slammed around. Republicans continue to introduce amendments exempting various sympathetic institutions, farmers, schools, small towns. And they continue to pass with majority Democratic support. And then the Democrats turn around and introduce amendments that directly contradict the ones they just voted yes to, tightening regulations and increasing fees.
关于费用法案的辩论在这之后持续了很长时间，进行了四个小时，直到下午6点，远远超过了会议通常结束的时间。其中一项法案最终通过了。但另一项却不断受到抨击。共和党人继续提出豁免各种有同情心的机构、农民、学校、小城镇的修正案。它们继续以多数民主党支持而通过。然后民主党人反过来提出直接与他们刚刚投赞成票的修正案相矛盾的修正案，收紧法规并增加费用。
Thank you, Mr. Speaker. This amendment to increase fees for chronic violators of the Clean Water Act serves two important purposes.
谢谢，主席先生。这个增加《清洁水法》慢性违规者费用的修正案有两个重要目的。
These fail, entirely along party lines. There's a highly choreographed feel to the whole thing. People don't cheer and high-five when their amendments pass. And they don't slam their briefcases on their desks when they fail. They're not trying to persuade each other or even to win. Each vote, each amendment, each speech for the record is solely about targeting the other party's positions at election time. The Republicans are trying to catch the Democrats raising taxes on the Boy Scouts. And the Democrats are trying to get the Republicans on record voting against clean drinking water.
这些失败了，完全按照党派路线。整个事情有一种高度编排的感觉。当他们的修正案通过时，人们不会欢呼和击掌。当它们失败时，他们也不会把公文包摔在桌子上。他们不是在试图说服对方甚至赢。每一次投票，每一个修正案，每一次为了记录的演讲，完全是为了在选举时针对对方政党的立场。共和党人正试图抓住民主党人提高童子军的税收。而民主党人正试图让共和党人在反对清洁饮用水的记录上签字。
But not everything in the day goes according to script. There is exactly one time in the entire debate when someone introduces an amendment as a matter of personal conviction, and not as a matter of party strategy.
但这一天并非所有事情都按照剧本进行。在整个辩论中，确实有一次有人引入修正案是出于个人信念，而不是出于党派战略。
The purpose of this--
这个的目的——
A Republican representative, Jack Brandenburg, introduces an amendment that mandates surprise on-site inspections at companies that pollute. In other words, that actually strengthens the environmental provisions of the bill. And he does it for the simple reason that he's worried about all the bad stuff going into the water.
一名共和党代表杰克·布兰登堡引入了一项强制对污染公司进行突击现场检查的修正案。换句话说，那实际上加强了法案的环境条款。他这样做是因为他担心所有进入水中的坏东西。
Currently, there are 600 toxins that if not discharged properly, are harmful to the health of human beings. Some of the most commonly discharged toxins are the following-- Mercury, linked to immune disorders and brain damage. Barium--
目前，有600种毒素，如果处理不当，对人类健康是有害的。一些最常见的排放毒素如下——汞，与免疫障碍和脑损伤有关。钡——
Brandenburg talks for a long time before Steve and the Democrats even realize it's not the usual offering from the other side of the aisle.
布兰登堡讲了很长时间，直到史蒂夫和民主党人才意识到这不是来自另一侧阵营的惯常提议。
We should all be voting for this.
我们都应该投票支持这个。
Well, I'll vote for this.
好吧，我会为这个投票。
The Republicans are realizing the same thing. You can hear the murmuring increase as people try to figure out what's going on.
共和党人也意识到同样的事情。你可以听到窃窃私语声增加，人们试图弄清楚发生了什么。
Copper is the most frequently discharged toxin into the Great Lakes, but we have not yet determined if this is in any way an effect on our health. May I have a little respect here please. Mr. Speaker?
铜是排放到五大湖中最频繁的毒素，但我们尚未确定这是否对我们的健康有任何影响。请在这里尊重一点。主席先生？
You may proceed, Representative.
你可以继续，代表。
All right.
好吧。
Brandenburg finishes. The Clerk opens the board. And much more slowly than on any of the other votes, names begin to appear, one after another, many of them green. Republicans voting for a fellow Republican. And the Clerk closes the board. And it looks like the measure has actually passed. But then, the Clerk doesn't tally the results. Sits quietly, watches the Republican floor leader, who's talking heatedly into the phone at his desk. Other Republican leaders circulate around their colleagues. And gradually screen names start switching to red.
布兰登堡讲完了。书记官打开板面。而且比任何其他投票都慢得多，名字开始出现，一个接一个，许多是绿色的。共和党人投票支持一位共和党同僚。书记官关闭板面。看起来该措施实际上通过了。但是，书记官没有计算结果。安静地坐着，看着共和党楼层领导，他在办公桌前对着电话激动地交谈。其他共和党领导人在他们的同事周围走动。逐渐地，屏幕上的名字开始切换为红色。
Representative Middaugh votes nay. Representative Palsrok votes nay.
米达夫议员投反对票。帕尔斯罗克议员投反对票。
At one point, I witness a classic backroom political horse trade done right out in the open, in the most blatant way possible, in the middle of the chamber floor. Virgil Smith, a Democrat from Detroit, sees which way the wind is blowing. Sees that the Republican floor leader isn't going to close the board until he gets enough no votes from his own party to kill the amendment.
有一次，我目睹了一个经典的幕后政治交易，就在大庭广众之下，以最公然的方式，在会议大厅地板中间。底特律民主党人维吉尔·史密斯看到了风向。看到共和党楼层领导直到他从自己政党获得足够的反对票来扼杀该修正案之前不会关闭板面。
And so Representative Smith decides to help them and help himself. He gets up, walks across the floor with his arm held above his head, and his thumb pointed straight up in the air, as if he were raising his hand in school and giving the thumbs sign at the same time. He walks right up to the Republican floor leader, Randy Richardville, who's huddled on the phone, surrounded by his advisers. And he stands there, with his thumb in the air. Richardville puts down the phone, looks up at him, they have a brief conversation. And then, Representative Smith walks back to his seat, still with his arm in the air, but this time with his thumb pointed down. Whatever happened, he's now voting nay.
所以史密斯议员决定帮助他们并帮助自己。他站起来，举着胳膊穿过地板，拇指笔直指向空中，就像他在学校举手并在同一时间做拇指手势一样。他径直走向被顾问包围、在电话里蜷缩的共和党楼层领导兰迪·理查德维尔。他站在那里，拇指指向空中。理查德维尔放下电话，抬头看着他，他们进行了短暂的交谈。然后，史密斯议员走回座位，胳膊仍然举在空中，但这次拇指指向下方。无论发生了什么，他现在在投反对票。
Representative Smith votes nay.
史密斯议员投反对票。
He put nay. What did you get for that, Virgil?
他投了反对票。你为此得到了什么，维吉尔？
He got something.
他得到了一些东西。
He got something for that. Because they didn't want this to pass.
他为此得到了一些东西。因为他们不希望这个通过。
And it doesn't pass. After a brief digression from the day's script, Republican leaders continue turning green votes to red, until they have what they need.
结果它没有通过。在偏离当天的剧本后，共和党领导人继续将绿色选票转为红色，直到他们得到他们需要的东西。
Tally, display, and announce the vote.
计数，显示，并宣布投票结果。
Mr. Speaker, on the question of adoption of the Brandenburg Amendment 2D, there are 51 aye votes and 52 nay votes.
主席先生，关于通过布兰登堡修正案2D的问题，有51张赞成票和52张反对票。
A sufficient number of members having not voted in the affirmative, the Brandenburg Amendment 2D is not adopted. There are further amendments--
足够数量的成员没有投赞成票，布兰登堡修正案2D未通过。还有进一步的修正案——
The weirdest maneuver of the day though, comes at the very end. After spending all day adding amendment after amendment, the Republicans introduce one final amendment. It comes at the very end. And it's rushed through on a procedural maneuver, without a record vote. Steve and all the Democrats scramble around to try and figure out what it says.
当天最奇怪的举动是在最后。在花费整天添加修正案之后，共和党人引入了最后一个修正案。它在最后到来。它通过程序性手段匆忙通过，没有进行记录投票。史蒂夫和所有的民主党人都忙着弄清楚它说了什么。
What did they do here?
他们在这里做了什么？
What did they just do?
他们刚刚做了什么？
Even the press guy for the Republican party is caught off guard, has to head out to the floor to find out what it does. He comes back and tells us with a sheepish smile, basically it takes us back in time three hours. It returns Senate Bill 560 to its original language, stripping off every amendment the Republicans had added, undoing everything Republicans had spent the past three hours doing. Then the Republicans bring this new bill, which is now the same as the old bill, to a vote and it fails. And then the Republican majority leader, Rick Johnson, holds a press conference in which he blames the Democrats, the minority party, and the only ones who actually voted for the bill, for its failure.
甚至共和党的新闻人员也被搞得措手不及，不得不前往楼层查明它做了什么。他回来带着腼腆的笑容告诉我们，基本上它把我们带回了三小时前。它将参议院法案560号恢复为原始语言，剥离了共和党人添加的每一个修正案，撤销了共和党人过去三小时所做的一切。然后共和党人将这个现在与旧法案相同的新法案付诸表决，结果失败了。然后共和党多数党领袖瑞克·约翰逊举行了新闻发布会，他指责民主党，少数党，以及唯一真正为该法案投票的人，造成了它的失败。
In the process, they made Steve Tobacman waste half his day on a huge turkey shoot that helped no one in his district. On the car ride home, we discussed the day. It wasn't all bad. He did manage to get some minor amendment, something to do with fraudulent notary publics, through a committee earlier in the day.
在这个过程中，他们让史蒂夫·托博克曼在他的一天中浪费了一半时间在一次对他选区没有人有帮助的巨大表演上。在回家的车上，我们讨论了这一天。并非全都很糟糕。他确实设法在一天早些时候通过了一个委员会，通过了一些小修正案，关于欺诈性公证人的事情。
He tells me that so far the best moment of his political career was the first, election night. It was early in the evening and returns were still coming in. He was standing in front of all supporters. And for the first time, he thought to himself it doesn't matter whether I win or lose. I ran a great campaign. I took no money. I spoke about issues that I believed in. I did everything exactly according to my beliefs. Driving home tonight after a long confusing day at his new job, as the rain poured symbolically down from the sky, that night feels very far away.
他告诉我，到目前为止，他政治生涯中最美好的时刻是第一次，选举之夜。那是在傍晚，结果还在陆续出炉。他站在所有的支持者面前。他第一次对自己说，我赢或输并不重要。我进行了一场伟大的竞选。我没有拿钱。我谈论了我所相信的议题。我完全按照我的信念做了一切。今晚在他新工作中度过了一个漫长而令人困惑的一天后开车回家，当雨水象征性地从天而降时，那个夜晚感觉非常遥远。
Do you find it like, yesterday we drive around your district. And then we go to this like redlining meeting where it's very local. And then I come into that chamber, and then there's this like elaborate political game that's going on. It's hard to see the connection sometimes. It was hard for me. Is it sometimes hard for you?
你发现它像，昨天我们开车绕过你的选区。然后我们去参加了这个非常本地化的红线会议。然后我进入那个大厅，然后那里发生了这种精致的政治游戏。有时很难看到联系。对我来说很难。有时对你来说很难吗？
Oh, absolutely. I mean today's activity was a bunch of pageantry. And it really does not in my mind impact the quality of life too greatly. And that I ask myself all the time. And I continually to ask myself. You might go out there and you find yourself advocating for the Todman bill or for pollution discharge permits fees. Or you can't really produce the results to end insurance redlining that you want to produce. And you feel, wow, I'm a total fraud up here. Here I am talking about something I truly, honestly believe in. And I'm doing everything I can. But at the end of the day, what kind of impact am I having? And is there a different thing I should be doing that my life? And is all of this worth that kind of trouble?
哦，绝对。我的意思是今天的活动是一堆盛况。这在我的脑海中并没有太大影响生活质量。我一直在问自己。我不断地问自己。你可能会走出去，发现自己在为托德曼法案或污染排放许可费进行辩护。或者你无法产生你想要产生的结束保险红线的结果。你觉得，哇，我在这里是个彻底的骗子。我在这里谈论一些我真正、诚实相信的事情。我正在尽我所能。但在一天结束时，我有什么影响？是否有我生命中应该做的其他事情？这一切是否值得那种麻烦？
In Steve's freezer at home in Detroit, there's two foot long pork loin. It's been there for 10 months. It was a Christmas present sent to him by some lobbying group, right after he got elected. Steve's not sure who sent it to him or what it's supposed to get him to do, let alone why anyone thought sending a huge piece of non-kosher meat to a Jew before Christmas would help with anything. Or for that matter, why they ignored the obvious negative symbolism of sending pork to a politician.
在史蒂夫底特律家中的冰箱里，有一块两英尺长的猪腰肉。它已经在那里10个月了。那是他刚当选后，某个游说团体送给他的圣诞礼物。史蒂夫不确定是谁送给他的，或者它应该让他做什么，更不用说为什么有人认为在圣诞节前给一个犹太人送一大块非犹太洁食的肉会有什么帮助。或者就此而言，为什么他们忽略了给一个政治家送猪肉的明显负面象征意义。
In the end, so much of politics is about hope. Somewhere there's a guy at some pork council putting mailing labels on boxes of meat, thinking maybe this will help. And for Steve, making any connection between what he does on a daily basis and what he actually wants to do requires a similar leap of faith. But the compromises he makes now will reward him later. And that somewhere down the line, performances like the one today in Lansing will do some good for someone back in Detroit.
最终，太多的政治是关于希望。某个地方有个家伙在某个猪肉委员会给肉盒贴邮寄标签，想着也许这会有帮助。对于史蒂夫来说，在他每天所做的和他真正想做的事情之间建立任何联系都需要类似的信念之跃。但他现在做出的妥协将在以后奖励他。在未来的某个时刻，像今天在兰辛那样的表现会为底特律的某个人带来好处。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
Act 3, Zero Divided by Zero Is Still Zero. This is a story of somebody trying out a new theory on how to run her life. Specifically, how to handle money. It's an excerpt from the book Random Family, in which a reporter named Adrian Nicole LeBlanc spent over 10 years following some people who were living in the Bronx. One of the people is Coco, who is in her early 20s at this point in the story, in this excerpt. She has kids. She's on welfare. And at this point in Coco's story, she's living in a church-run residence called Thorpe House, trying to get her life together with the help of the nuns. Actress Liza Colon-Zayas reads the excerpt.
第三幕，零除以零仍然是零。这是一个关于某人试图为她的人生制定新理论的故事。具体来说，是如何处理金钱。这是《随机家庭》一书的摘录，其中一位名叫阿德里安·妮可·勒布朗的记者花了10多年时间追踪一些住在布朗克斯的人。其中一个人是可可，她在故事的这一点上，在这个摘录中，她是20多岁。她有孩子。她在领福利金。在可可故事的这一点上，她住在一个叫索普之家的教会运营的住宅里，在修女的帮助下试图整理她的生活。女演员丽莎·科隆-扎亚斯阅读了该摘录。
Coco was eager to devise a plan for her future. Coco responded most enthusiastically to the workshops on money and budgeting. Every two weeks, she received $125 from welfare, by which time she was often $110 in debt. The Thorpe House covered utilities and rent. Coca hoped the budgeting workshops would teach her how to stop having to struggle-- a problem for which she blamed herself.
可可渴望为她的未来制定计划。可可对金钱和预算的研讨会反响最热烈。每两周，她从福利机构收到125美元，到那时她经常欠债110美元。索普之家支付水电费和租金。可可希望预算研讨会能教她如何停止挣扎——她将这个问题归咎于自己。
The day checks arrived was pickup day. After she picked up, Coco immediately accounted for one top priority-- People I Owe Money To. She always owed someone something-- $8 to Thorpe for change for washing, $6 to a neighbor for food, $15 to Dayland, a drug dealer from around her mother's way, who had lent her $200 the previous Christmas when she had no money for gifts. Coco earmarked the cash by writing the names, "Dayland's" "Sheila's"-- on the actual bills. She also deducted for subway tokens to get to appointments and put money aside for a cab in case of emergency. It wasn't unusual for her to have $5 left, which she then had to stretch for the next two weeks.
支票到达的那天是领取日。领取支票后，可可立即考虑了一个首要任务——我欠钱的人。她总是欠某人钱——欠索普8美元换洗衣服的零钱，欠邻居6美元买食物，欠戴兰（来自她母亲那边的一名毒贩）15美元，去年圣诞节她在没有钱买礼物时借了200美元。可可通过在账单上写上名字——“戴兰的”、“希拉的”来指定现金用途。她还扣除了地铁代币以去参加预约，并为紧急情况存了一点钱以备乘出租车。她剩下5美元的情况并不罕见，然后她必须在接下来的两周内紧缩开支。
She usually owed someone food stamps. Luckily, Coco's girls were under five and still qualified for WIC-- Women, Infants, and Children-- a supplemental food program for specified items-- eggs, cereal, and most preciously, milk. What remained of the money went to clothes for the girls and necessary toiletries. Children's looks reflected the quality of mothering. Sloppiness and dirt were physical evidence of failure, of poverty winning its battle against you. Coco would keep the girls indoors rather than let them look busted-up outside. She spent hours on their hair, twisting and tugging, braiding and curling, liberally applying Vaseline. When she was done, she'd briskly rub her palms together and wipe down each daughter's face. Vaseline also kept their skin from getting patchy. "I want them to perfect. They are so beautiful," Coco said. Weeks ahead of time, Coco estimated the price of clothes she wanted for her girls, including the tax. As soon as she possibly could, she'd make a deposit and put them on layaway.
她通常欠某人食品券。幸运的是，可可的女孩们不到五岁，仍然有资格获得WIC——妇女、婴儿和儿童补充食品计划——用于特定物品——鸡蛋、谷物，以及最珍贵的牛奶。剩下的钱用于给女孩买衣服和必要的洗漱用品。孩子的长相反映了母亲的质量。懒散和肮脏是失败的身体证据，是贫穷在你身上打赢了它的战争。可可会把女孩们关在室内，而不是让她们在外面看起来破破烂烂。她花数小时在她们的头发上，扭曲和拉扯，编辫子和卷曲，慷慨地涂抹凡士林。当她完成时，她会用力摩擦她的手掌，擦拭每个女儿的脸。凡士林也防止了她们的皮肤变得斑驳。“我希望她们完美。她们太美了，”可可说。提前几周，可可估算了她想为女孩买的衣服的价格，包括税。一旦她能做到，她就会存钱并把它们放在预留单上。
But budgeting didn't mitigate one of Coco's greatest problems-- everyone around her also needed, and Coco didn't know how to refuse. Sometimes Coco would spend down her money just so she could be the one to use it, allowing her to maintain her integrity. That way if someone asked her for money, she could honestly tell them no, she didn't have it.
但预算并没有减轻可可最大的问题之一——她周围的每个人也需要钱，而可可不知道如何拒绝。有时可可会花光她的钱，只是为了让她成为使用它的人，让她保持她的正直。那样如果有人向她要钱，她可以诚实地告诉他们不，她没有。
The cash had to stretch further with Coco's boyfriend Cesar jailed. He needed winter boots, a coat, socks, towels, and sheets, and commissary money for his hygiene and stamps. Then he'd ask for extra things like a door-size reproduction of his favorite photograph of their daughter Mercedes with her hair in Shirley Temple curls. Coco didn't know how to tell him no. "The welfare money, that's the girls'. It belongs to the girls, not him," she would say, but only to herself.
随着可可的男朋友塞萨尔入狱，现金必须进一步紧缩。他需要冬季靴子、外套、袜子、毛巾和床单，以及用于他的卫生和邮票的佣金费。然后他会要求额外的东西，比如他最喜欢的他们女儿梅赛德斯的照片的门大小的复制品，头发卷成秀兰·邓波儿的卷发。可可不知道如何对他拒绝。“福利金，那是女孩们的。它属于女孩们，不属于他，”她会对自己说，但只对自己说。
Coco's sister, Iris, however, knew how to take care of business. Her method was a stern personality. She could ward off potential borrowers with one stony look. Coco couldn't live like that. Coco was too open. Even if she avoided being a bank for near strangers, she ended up as the neighborhood grocery store. People would be knocking at all hours of the day and night, "Coco, you got this? Coco, you got that?'"
然而，可可的姐姐艾里斯知道如何处理业务。她的方法是一种严厉的个性。她可以用一种冷酷的眼神挡住潜在的借款人。可可无法那样生活。可可太开放了。即使她避免成为近乎陌生人的银行，她最终也成了邻里杂货店。人们会在白天和晚上的所有时间敲门，“可可，你有这个吗？可可，你有那个吗？”
Coco's Thorpe House case worker, Sister Christine, worried about Coco's generosity. You either made your way by hardening up, like Iris, or you stayed stuck. Coco didn't see a choice. Coco couldn't ignore the people she cared for, which is why everyone turned to her first for help. The word that came to Sister Christine's mind whenever she thought of Coco was enmeshed. Coco would have said she had heart.
可可的索普之家个案工作者克里斯汀修女担心可可的慷慨。你要么通过变得坚强，像艾里斯那样谋生，要么你就被困住。可可没有看到选择。可可无法忽视她在乎的人，这就是为什么每个人都先向她寻求帮助。当克里斯汀修女想到可可时，脑海中浮现的词是“纠缠”。可可会说她有心。
One day, Coco and Iris went shopping. Although Coco had figured out her budget, she deferred to Iris, who she considered a financial whiz. Iris was the only person Coco knew who actually survived on her welfare benefits. "I'm going to give you my list of people I owe and you have to divide it up," Coco told her. At Youngland, Iris exchanged the $12.99 jeans Coco had put on layaway for a similar style Iris found for half the price. Coco would have never had the defiance to ignore the clerk's snooty look. Iris brought her to Big R Food Warehouse and suggested Coco buy the enormous packs of chicken and pork chops. Iris divided them into smaller portions and froze them separately. Coco often forgot to defrost meat in enough time for dinner. Iris had her children's school clothes pressed and laid on a chair the night before. Coco was constantly rummaging around for a hair brush or a matching sock. Coco knew she couldn't replicate Iris's strict adherence to order, but she longed for her girls to sleep in rooms like Iris's rooms. "They for beautiful people," Coco said. In her niece's bedroom, everything matched-- curtains, and bedspreads, and sheets.
有一天，可可和艾里斯去购物。尽管可可已经计算出了她的预算，但她还是听从了艾里斯，她认为艾里斯是一位金融专家。艾里斯是可可认识的唯一一个真正靠福利金生存下来的人。“我要给你看我欠钱的人的清单，你必须把它分配好，”可可告诉她。在Youngland，艾里斯换掉了可可放在预留单上的12.99美元牛仔裤，换成了艾里斯发现的一款半价的类似款式。可可永远不会有勇气忽视店员傲慢的眼神。艾里斯带她去了Big R食品仓库，建议可可购买巨大的鸡肉和猪排包装。艾里斯将它们分成较小的部分并分别冷冻。可可经常忘记在晚餐前及时解冻肉。艾里斯在晚上前把孩子的校服烫好放在椅子上。可可一直在翻找梳子或匹配的袜子。可可知道她无法复制艾里斯对秩序的严格遵守，但她渴望她的女孩们睡在像艾里斯房间那样的房间里。“她们适合美丽的人，”可可说。在她侄女的卧室里，一切都很匹配——窗帘、床罩和床单。
But Coco's pride in her sister's way was mixed with concern. The rigidity of Iris's approach to her predicament generated its own problems. Iris lived in a housing project, where it was dangerous to take the elevators too early in the morning, or late at night, alone. She rarely ventured anywhere without her husband, Armando-- even to visit family. And the toll of their vigilance could be seen in Armando's anxious eyes or the grim set of Iris's jaw. Mainly, though, it was Iris's unhappiness that upset Coco. The family anxiety projected an unspoken, unappealing truth-- that even living right, which was what Coco called it, was just another precarious hold. Poverty pulled everybody down. Coco loosened her body to minimize the impact of the fall. Iris and Armando froze, and the chill stiffened their kids, as well. Even indoors, when Armando planted himself in his favorite chair, he gripped the arms.
但可可对自己姐姐方式的自豪感中夹杂着担忧。艾里斯处理她困境的方法的刚性产生了它自己的问题。艾里斯住在公共住房项目中，清晨或深夜独自乘坐电梯很危险。她很少在没有她丈夫阿曼多的情况下冒险去任何地方——即使是探亲。这种警惕的代价可以在阿曼多焦虑的眼睛或艾里斯严峻的下颚线条中看到。但主要还是艾里斯的不快乐让可可难过。家庭焦虑投射出一个未言说、不吸引人的事实——即使是“生活得对”，也就是可可所称的那样，也只是另一种不稳定的立足点。贫穷拉低了每个人。可可放松她的身体以减轻跌倒的影响。艾里斯和阿曼多僵住了，寒冷也让他们的孩子僵住了。即使在室内，当阿曼多把自己种植在他最喜欢的椅子上时，他紧紧抓住扶手。
Liza Colon-Zayas, reading from Adrian Nicole LeBlanc's amazing book, Random Family.
丽莎·科隆-扎亚斯，阅读阿德里安·妮可·勒布朗的惊人书作《随机家庭》。
Our program was produced today by Starlee Kine and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, and Wendy Dorr. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Stacey Tiderington. This is our last show with our intern Stacey Tiderington. She has faced down some very fierce deadlines with us. We wish her the best.
我们的节目今天由斯塔利·凯恩和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克和温迪·多尔参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。托德·巴赫曼和斯泰西·泰德林顿提供了制作帮助。这是我们实习生斯泰西·泰德林顿的最后一次节目。她和我们一起面对了一些非常激烈的截止日期。我们祝她一切顺利。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助信用]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who proves that he is a true Chicagoan every November when he calls us in and declares,
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他证明了自己是一名真正的芝加哥人，每年的十一月，当他叫我们进去并宣布时，
So let's rig an election.
所以让我们来操纵一次选举吧。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。